the best of the Americans working hard
playing hard Americans in the asset
column because of sacrifice and risk and
work ethic and productivity and in
dedication to God family country every
time those Democrats speak the good
Americans the country going huh yeah now
let me ask you so do you always take it
in stride in the sense that you know
some performers get nervous before they
go onstage ivo has been one of those
people so before stand-up I would always
get really nervous some people love it
but have you been the latter your whole
life or did you start off Conor six
thousand seven hundred and seventeen
concerts later
I am so enthused about going on stage
and I've been clean and sober for 70
years I've no drugs no alcohol no
tobacco no fat girlfriends that's stuff
so I my stuff works pretty good how far
can I go on the Capades
take it away the only way to accurately
and honestly express my life is that my
entire being is like a purple rim it's
really susceptible to any stimuli I
really am energized by all things life
in matter speaking there kind of all
dogs are purple rim defective breathing
it's like I I don't miss a thing when I
get ready to go on stage I can't wait to
play these licks it's like a horny kid
in a garage at the age of 12 with this
first loud amp that's an analogy that'll
be lost on some think with an iphone
know it from some kids who don't get the
garage is practice do you know there's
actually calluses on my hand it's called
work ethic you never look it up I don't
think of calluses too but just because
pornography's get nervous but I am
really really excited first off I'm
somewhat jealous because I've always
been a very anxious person before
performances for me I hate it I get
nervous I want to quit before every
stand-up but you have confidence what
you're about to do no oh no here's
actually what happened I have this
window where I go I've forgotten
everything because I've had nightmares
like this where I go out on stage and
realize
and then I go out there and after the
first laugh I go into autopilot what if
there wasn't a first laughs then I want
to swallow a knife but before going on
stage very nervous and then on stage
enjoy and by the way it really door Greg
and Jason and I and this weekend John
and Johnny and I play for the music the
music my Breck my new records called the
music made me do it
and that goes all the way back to when I
was seven or eight hearing this new
outrageous Little Richard stuff are you
kidding me in Chuck Berry and Bo Diddley
how can you not be motivated to dance
not just literally but figuratively
through life right with that kind of
authoritative soulful black powerful
music so luckily here is twenty nineteen
are you kidding me and I still look I
love it more now than ever so I don't
have time to be nervous I just have to
calm myself down what that'll be the day
so that I remain musical sure in in the
intensity of my musical love is
unleashed upon fellow music find a
reason to you get so enthused you just
mentioned the great musicians you work
with for me before I do a show or even
before we do this show
I can't watch I don't like watching
myself but I get really excited to see
what they do so if it's a sketch or
there's some kind of After Effects or
some post work I go oh man this isn't
like me watching myself I get to see
what the whole team put together and
I'll sit and watch those sketches or sit
and watch you know blood forming
something cuz it gets me excited because
work yeah you know for me it's all prep
I don't know when you're performing in
this you don't really get to enjoy it as
much it's not like music in the same way
where um you don't feel it the same way
stand-up you do well I you gotta come to
my show I am stand up I'm like Sam
Kinison meets Richard Pryor with his
afro on fire I'm a funny funny son of a
shot stage I I intertwine a means think
of the songs it's serious songs like
fredbear and stranglehold which is the
greatest love song ever but when I break
into a Wango Tango or Wang dang sweet
poontang I wax eloquently my wife waxed
eloquently last week it was awesome and
on stage no private affair all right and
so I I go into
outrageous you know anecdotal
histrionics of my own personal
adventures almost like Lewis and Clark
with Sacagawea on stage and off and I'm
able to get a lot of a lot of chuckles
on the out of the audience every night
in fact you go to my facebook people say
it's the funniest comedy routine and the
greatest rock how much of that do you
think is like is writing versus like
being you know like ostentatious pricky
I had probably a hundred percent mine
have to be on fire but so I use that
wherever I can
it's well and I think that's what people
probably really appreciate about people
and not just not not just yourself but
there I feel like there's um I was just
reading an interview I think recently
maybe not recently but was with Alice
Cooper and now Rob Zombie and they were
talking about friends yeah you've seen a
lot of the hard rock guys because they
came from the Midwest and working-class
backgrounds they've had more longevity a
lot of them if you look at how they're
touring and how even you know obviously
they're out in the road right now yeah
me I'm creating more me that's right in
your tour start your next tour is next
next month July and August all across
the hinterland yes that's called like
made me do it again right he's lucky me
the music made me do it again he Steven
I can tell by the look in your eye you
have to see my band you have want to see
this music there's no music like this
this is where the last of them I would
love to see it at one of the
Scandinavian shows you just mentioned
that because that seems like would be a
trip do these sing along in English they
do absolutely that's against the law
over this we're in Japan last year
played in Okinawa for the Marines god am
i lucky and I go on my Facebook we got
people from every imaginable culture
Society part of the world geography it's
fascinating because music is a universal
communication yeah and when you unleash
it without any pre thought any pretense
any filter any PC worried that someone
might have their feathers ruffled by the
way I don't ruffle feathers I pluck them
and and you'll see that what I represent
is available everywhere
Scandinavia they don't have a
constitution the British don't have a
constitution they don't really have the
freedoms that are unique to this
wonderful experiment self-government but
they hear it and it's relative to what
you just said about Detroit
what Motown Mitch Ryder in the Detroit
wheels the mc5 now with Kid Rock and
even Eminem I'm not a big fan of that
kind of music but he certainly has a
musical authority all the way back to
the rationals and Brownsville station
and the Scott Richardson cases so many
bands just unbelievable bands in
Michigan what do you think it is about
Detroit well I hope people write this
down the definitive soulfulness and
authority of all things Motown that was
exemplified by my Amboy Dukes band
certainly Brownsville station certainly
the mc5 before the drugs destroyed them
right and certainly Bob Seger it was all
rhythm and blues it was all gospel it
was all blues oriented James Brown was a
bigger influence before the storms and
the Beatles were ever heard of right and
Chuck Berry and boat did little with a
lot of the early Beatles songs too boy
the first needles and stones out was
Chuck Berry songs Bo Diddley songs and
Motown writes because it was inescapable
if you loved any kind of music the the
the work ethic that the Funk Brothers in
the basement of Hitsville USA and all
the bands I just mentioned we practice
our asses raw there was a competition
not to beat the other band but to beat
tighter to have more adventurous music
to have whatever it was that Chuck and
Bo and little richer than these black
monsters of authoritative music coming
out of the worst crime of mankind
slavery blues heartbreak anger
frustration to the celebration that
Chuck Berry and Bo Diddley's up again
this brought to it and Little Richard
personified it that free free at last
yeah there's when I'm Jam and there's no
Hillary Clinton there's no Benghazi
there's no you know open borders there's
no you know killing babies on tables
there's
Oh hate for a Mary there's no politics
there's no negative there's no pain
there's no suffering it is so cleansing
and it fortifies you so you can go when
you're done with the cleansing you can
go and attack those evil things that are
ruining America do you think while you
were when you were hypothetically in
your next sort of out-of-body experience
talking about sort of being that one
pulsating entity in the music do you
think it'd be distracted if they don't
work came by in a skateboard I've caused
him to crash though I promise you that
that's something he would do is to try
and appeal to the youngins and bend with
gentleness and almost parental type
authority we'd strap his lame ass to my
amplifiers that you mentioned urn mag
Detroit also became kind of a proving
ground you know when I used to read up
on and my mother-in-law you know toured
with Aretha Franklin Joni Mitchell
Stevie Nicks is a Grateful Dead so she
was a backup singer for a lot of them
know and on for she could tell you some
story I'll price of me over here if you
make him Detroit you can make it
anywhere because those people know music
yeah and she she has some stories when
her father passed when she was really
young so she was touring as a teenager
basically would sometimes I think after
she's gone lie about her age to even get
into some of these vans awesome
adventures yeah she's all those
adventures with you yeah but I don't
know what I'm allowed to tell because
now she is just she's the sweetest you
know Christian lady great fantastic I
don't touch at all but she doesn't want
to know probably some of the the magic
mushrooms that she took back in the well
I was against all that because I had to
step over all these great friends and
phenomenally gifted musicians I mean if
you could have if the world could have
just witnessed gregor rama this bass
player this kid from Detroit played in
the first Amboy Dukes jury the center of
the mind he mean the Funk Brothers would
come and watch us to watch Greg play
yeah and then the the lie the
peer-pressured nonsense
scam it it took so many of them over you
know there's strong people in those weak
people and if there's any moment of
weakness you start thinking that
comfortably numb' will make you play
better yeah I don't want my bass player
comfortably numb' prior to the election
night in 2016 where I wrapped up my wall
paper carpet bomb PR campaign obviously
PR stands for public relations I related
to the public with truth logic and
common sense you know radical stuff like
the Constitution the Bill of Rights
Declaration of Independence Ten
Commandments golden rule II and all that
every nasty stuff yeah and I did a
Facebook live from my Michigan cabin
very emotional because I was with Trump
till 3:00 in the morning and the night
election night and as the numbers were
coming in I saw the results and I didn't
do it alone the National Rifle
Association and great families and the
real Republicans out there and just
working hard playing hard Americans
including the Teamsters and the typical
unions that always went Democrat yeah
and the most embarrassing apathetic
segment of our society
society the Second Amendment people and
the hunting population they just didn't
vote in a meaningful way then when I saw
that we won those 3s everybody's gonna
be making Wisconsin a Pennsylvanian and
Hillary's gonna get all those huh and
then all of a sudden night I was I
remember that video yeah yeah did you
see my yeah when we talked about I
remember you talked about how Michigan
came home some of my point is is that
that is still possible but here's the
technical logic here's the Google sucker
burger world the week before I think we
talked about this last time it's
important to return to restate it I add
between 15 million and 36 million
Facebookers I was like up there with
Beyonce and and Taylor Swift yeah and
and then the the next couple days it
went down to three and a half million
really yes I had 15 million to 36
million it was on record I don't know if
you can still get back there probably
scrub that but that's how many
Facebookers I had my reach and then all
of a sudden my Nugent's to makes too
much sense connects with too many people
got too much information out there we
need to stop that right and so that's
that's a censorship indicator from the
left and from these high tech you know
comfortably numb' goofballs that is
really a scourge that is is it's not
overwhelming it but to overcome it
should be job one of people who believe
in the Constitution and the basics of
America got a family country I think
it's it's it's also harder we're sort of
handicapped and overcoming it because
it's not a thought process that
conservatives would employ we don't
really think about shutting down voices
traditionally have been very much like
Mitt Romney they well no but I mean
people like you and I wouldn't even
think of wanting to ban someone so it's
tough for us sometimes go well how do we
solve this problem because we're trying
to go through the thought process of
getting rid of anyone who disagrees with
us which just really isn't a part of
what we typically do yeah you can leave
it up that's fine I'm not I'm I'm the
original liberal que sera sera whatever
will be will be live it up choose your
own path and life just don't you know
defecate upstream of my pursuit of
happiness right you like to defecate in
your water be sure you do it away from
the water table so those of us
personally happen is downstream from you
don't have to live with your stupid
choices right um yeah I'm the original
libertarian liberal but now it's been
bastardized and completely altered to
where now they're just it's like the gal
that finally got her comeuppance when
she took the sign away from a a pro-life
guy and when the the abortion freak in
California attacked that old man and
knocked him down and beat him because he
disagreed with them I would if you
disagree with me I will never beat you
up yeah just be very careful don't try
to beat me up right exactly yeah I was
just recently a brewery we were just
telling us on Twitter a brewery was
calling people to hit fascists in the UK
over the head with a brick oh yeah over
the head with a brick this was an actual
brewery and they were and by fascist it
means you know Nigel Faraj it means
anyone has agrees with them that's the
problem I mean the
the problem with this never talked about
this is when you dehumanize your
opposition in the sense that if Adolf
Hitler were here right now right
post-world War two all the atrocities
committed I don't think it would be
unreasonable for someone to try and get
them for someone to try and nail Hitler
I don't think so I'd get him yeah
exactly yeah but now they've made you
and myself and everyone here out to be a
Nazi to be Hitler so when you equivocate
that it makes it okay to treat them now
and ultimate fighters against Nazis
right yeah yeah you would think so it's
craziness but but you know not big fans
of the Socialists we are hey let me ask
you this try the Nationalists you just
mentioned Michigan what do you think
20/20 do you think Trump wins Michigan
again huh boy you know I got dice and
I'm ready to roll them now spit on him
and make a cup of prayers because we
didn't exactly landslide it in 2016
yeah and I got to tell you I've said it
before a lot of people are angry at me
because I'm properly condemning the
politics of Michigan I'm not condemning
the good families of Michigan still a
bunch of them but when you have the
illegitimate Punk daughter of Hillary
Clinton as the governor and you've got a
constitutional oath violate and Attorney
General in the once great state of
Michigan and mark my words born in 1948
and Detroit everyone knows that Michigan
in Detroit was the productivity and work
ethic epicenter of mankind we were the
arsenal of democracy I was raised to do
everything to the absolute best of your
ability to get up early work harder than
anybody else stay late and be proud of
your accomplishments every day whether
it's painting the fence delivering
newspapers or building four words
the pride of ownership and success and
excellence was ubiquitous and universal
literally everywhere you look people
cared and they were always there for
each other and then I saw this liberal
scourge metastasizing and you can stay
home and we'll still send you a check
and hey you're making too many widgets
on the assembly line if you could back
it down and get you double overtime
and if you break some of them we can get
you more money by replacing the ones
that you intentionally made inferior
right don't believe me when I tell you
this I've had them tell I know I bet you
actually I was the stamp made in America
it doesn't always necessarily means
better anymore so now if nothing breaks
my heart more then to witness the
greatest state in the nation still with
an incredible population of the greatest
friendliest most loving generous giving
hard-working funny cocky music loving
maniacs that ever walked the earth to
see it turn into a suburb of San
Francisco a sanctuary Hell where they
intentionally disincentivize people not
just from excellence to mediocrity but
from nothingness to Slaven leanness
where they just expect generational
handouts and they get fat and stupid in
enslaved by a liberal Democrat scam yeah
they try to blame it you know the left
they try to blame it on it being a
single horse town with the automotive
industry that's now when it started in
this huge agriculture right now how
about this how about what was also
before the automotive industry
diversified Detroit's downturn in the
60s so it wasn't it you can go back to
Jerome Cavanaugh in the model cities
before yeah um yeah I hate the state I
think I think Bert I think and
everyone's gonna get mad at me if I say
this I think if Bernie is the nominee he
probably would win Michigan he had a lot
of wealth that would be the next stabbed
in the heart wouldn't it yeah I'll tell
you this given up no with that I should
not Michigan Wisconsin Pennsylvania Ohio
I'm not giving up an anything how about
this how about the worst heartbreak of
all I could name a bunch of them what's
happened to Sam from what's happened to
California and I know real California
real California is not San Francisco or
LA I know real California it's the toxic
you know sanctuary city dog wagging the
tail wagging the otherwise red
constitutional dogs like Illinois New
York New Jersey Maryland Massachusetts
Connecticut Delaware
what Michigan what planet does that work
make life better what the abandonment of
the pillars of quality of life being
that as it may
boy we are cocked locked and ready to
rock the Glock dock we are rolling up
our sleeves and we're not going to give
up on any of those states I believe that
if we can do next year what we did in
2016
that we will once again make sure that
the non presidential guy you know the
old status quo
you know swamp deep state corrupt as a
way of life criminality James Comey
there's the most obnoxious disgusting
vulgar anti-american gang of punks the
world has ever known
I think that we can still do it if we
can get and it's going to be your
believe me when I tell you how you
respect your elders if we just get the
licensed hunting families to vote in
Michigan Wisconsin Pennsylvania Ohio and
elsewhere we judge especially those
states does there's millions of them if
we just got them and the real Teamsters
in the unions who have seen their
leadership lie to them year after year
and continue to whittle away at their
paychecks and whittle away at their
quality of life if we get that army of
conservative voters like we did in 2016
boom we got it especially if it's guys
that are going ah look at the split
screen on television this is socialism
in Venezuela and I think it'll work here
yeah what kind of how much LSD do you
have to shovel down your gullet to
actually think this way so I'm hoping
the truth logic common sense in that
goodwill and decency and work ethic that
is alive and well all across this
country I believe that if we just vote
yeah we'll have whatever we want to have
it all I hate to say it pains me to say
I think a good portion of that work
ethic though has been crippled in
Michigan because of the corrupt Union
leadership like you're talking about and
that's the thing that I think I think
that when you look at a lot of the Union
voting compared to Hillary Clinton who
was seen as elite versus Donald Trump
they preferred Donald Trump but I mean
no one panders to to that area that
sector of the country more than Bernie
Sanders and that's that's the challenge
I mean I just try to look at it
realistically when concerns say there's
no one who
beat him I think it was buying obviously
I think Donald Trump probably wins I
think Bernie could be a formidable
candidate in the Midwest yeah but if
what is that what does that tell you how
stupid D I mean the dumbing down of
America has been engineered right after
World War Two I mean just look at the
people in the left lane there's a big
giant sign left lane for passing only
thought oh yeah I'm driving my color
Delano they're in the left lane just
blocking traffic there's daylight for
miles in front of them and there's a
hundred fifty cars behind them and I got
that okay you son of a [ __ ] up yeah I
know so on air I had a knew a guy who
got a ticket for going slow in the left
lane and that's my favorite policeman
ever I'm gonna give tickets for going
slow on the left lane yeah my point is
it's a federal crime but yeah that's a
manifestation of a cultural deprivation
that has really impacted a unforgivable
segment of our population the dumbing
down of America gives you the current
Democrat Party it is brain testing it
that it it my family my bad my friends
my hunting buddies our spirit of the
wild production team our Ted Nugent camp
for kids volunteers 31 years Ted Nugent
camp for Kids charity 18,000 boys and
girls between 7 and 17 have graduated
from my children's charity 31 years
wouldn't be funny if one of them were
booty gag say again now wouldn't it be
funny if one of those kids was booty gig
it could have been cuz he was in a
military shot I understand could have
been good daughter love be decent guy
used to what I'm doing personally buddy
I understand he served great in the
military he has taken on one of the most
important duties of the human species
and that is to serve we the people by
the Constitution and I guess if he's
done that in South Bend for all these
years I suspect that he has some talents
that he is somehow abandoned during his
campaign to lie to himself and go the
ultra-left route to try to appease the
dumbest of the
so that's a whole different story but
Hollis candidates I mean if there was a
charity I could give to to keep these
numbnuts talking I donate lots of money
because every time they open their mouth
the best of the Americans working hard
playing hard Americans in the asset
column because of sacrifice and risk and
work ethic and productivity and in
dedication to God family country every
time those Democrats speak the good
Americans of the country go huh yeah
what well there's it you can give it
just the DNC drawer by the way is the
tour is the music let me do it again
my final clean it's a June July when you
start July July out California July all
the way through August Edina the first
here's the thing it will be the best
tour of my life Greg Smith on bass and
Jason Hart was 23 year old animal from
Detroit on drums it's it is the best
music if I wasn't in a band I'd go every
night and sat in the front row and dance
naked these guys are so good these songs
are so cool the guitar toned the bass
tone the drum tone Mike Cruz the best in
the world if we could have a military
like my crew there would be no wars we
had already wiped out all the bad guys
so I want to take this opportunity to
thank everybody for keeping this career
of mine going for 60 years are you
kidding me started playing to Detroit 60
years ago and every year the greatest
most intense enthusiastic music lovers
show up to all of my gigs and it's out
of body I thank them with all my greasy
backstrap and festive heart and soul
okay if you like this video you know you
watch videos on youtube if I were Jimmy
Kimmel if I were Stephen Colbert or
Trevor Noah I would tell you to
subscribe but I have no corporate
overlords who demand that I do this
demeaning promo I do the demeaning promo
because I choose to subscribe or hit the
notification bell because I need you I
need you please do it